good design begins with very basic
elements and once you understand what
these elements are
you can take any motion graphic design
to another level
the elements of art are varied in their
interpretations but for the sake of this
short training we are looking at
line
shape
space
size
form
color
tone
intensity and texture we can think of
these elements as a collection of
abstract building blocks
they can be combined and arranged in any
way we like to create a visual statement
let's start by breaking down lines
a line is a one-dimensional path created
by a point moving in space
they can vary in width
length
and direction
lines help to give alignment which leads
to appeal and order in design
they can indicate a state of rest when
horizontal
signify a sense of height when vertical
imply stability and solidity when
horizontal and vertical or suggest a
sense of movement when diagonal
they lead the eye in a composition and
communicate information through their
direction
lines can exist as elements in
themselves
or they can be used to produce other
elements like shapes
a shape is an element of design that is
usually defined by enclosed lines
it is two-dimensional with height and
width
a shape can be geometric and include
squares
rectangles and circles
or a shape can be organic irregular or
asymmetrical
a singular shape cannot exist without
generating another negative shape
the meeting of two defined shapes
produces a boundary line
the area around the primary object in a
composition is known as negative space
the area occupied by the object of focus
is known as positive space
the relationship between these two can
greatly affect the composition
size is the relationship between one
shape to that of another
differences in size can create
interesting relationships within a
composition
generally to have balance a large shape
requires the existence of a smaller
shape
shapes of equal size create focal
confusion
with the eye not knowing where to focus
by varying the size of the shapes the
eye is drawn to the larger dominant
shape
if the size difference is exaggerated
tension can be created
this tension can be used to add impact
to a composition
a form is an object that exists in space
as an enclosed volume with three
dimensions
height
width and depth examples of geometric
form are found in a cube
sphere
pyramid
or cylinder
a form can also be abstract and flow
freely
color is an element with three main
characteristics
hue
tone and intensity
hue is the descriptive name of color
red
green and blue are the three primary
hues and from these three
all other colors can be created
secondary colors contain a mixture of
two primaries
tertiary colors fall between any primary
color and its adjacent secondary
a tent is any color mixed with white
and a shade is any color mixed with
black
tone is simply the darkness or lightness
of an object
sometimes referred to as value tone is
one of the most powerful design elements
and helps to create different moods
white is the lightest value black is the
darkest
the value halfway between these extremes
is called middle gray
dark colors can suggest a sense of
mystery
light colors can describe a brighter
more energetic mood
in any design the area of highest
contrast between light and dark will
always demand maximum attention
the eye is naturally drawn to the area
of highest tonal contrast
color and tone are unique and separate
elements
all colors have a tone but tone can
exist without color
intensity is the strength of a color
bright colors are often associated with
positive energy and are undiluted
darker colors are more subdued and
create a more serious mood
lastly texture is an important art
element that can bring an extra layer of
depth and appeal to a composition the
use of textures is one of the most
powerful tools for creating compelling
graphic design without relying on the
complexity of many elements
texture can be drawn
painted or photographed
textures evoke emotion and bring life to
design
the contrast of highly textured visual
information and striking flat design is
always a winning strategy
although this list of elements seems
straightforward the more you study
design the more varied the list becomes
some add to the list and some subtract
from it the elements of design are not a
guaranteed recipe for design success but
if you use them correctly they are
extremely useful building blocks for
creating visual design